how's it going everybody it's Warren and
there has been a lot of talk recently
about Morgan Stark Morgan Stark would be
the daughter of Tony Stark's and pepper
potts
and in this video I'll break down all
the recent news about Morgan Stark being
in Avengers endgame but first there are
only five days left in the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway if you would like to
enter for your chance to win a life-size
Infinity Gauntlet all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero I
will be announcing the winner on
February 1st so in the very beginning of
Avengers infinity war there is a scene
with Tony Stark and Pepper Potts where
Tony is telling Pepper about a dream
that he had where they had a child
together I propose that last night I
dreamt we had a kid so real we named him
after your eccentric Uncle Bob what was
his name Morgan Morgan so you woke up in
Watchmen we were expecting he says that
they named the child after peppers
eccentric uncle Morgan and although
pepper denied being pregnant we do know
that Tony Stark and Pepper Potts will
have a child together and this child
will be in Avengers endgame Gweneth
Paltrow the actress that plays Pepper
Potts actually confirmed this in an
interview when she was asked about where
the relationship with pepper and Tony is
now she said pepper and Tony have had a
really long journey together
she obviously starts as his dutiful
assistant and then the relationship
evolves and now this decade later
they're married and they have a child
their relationship has evolved in all of
the ways that great romance has evolved
so it's officially confirmed right here
when she says that Tony Stark and Pepper
Potts will get married and indeed have a
child in Avengers end game but what role
will she actually play in the movie well
it has been confirmed that Catherine
Langford will play a character in
Avengers in game which character she was
playing was unknown for a very long time
because Marvel is being extra secretive
about everything relating to this movie
but recently Catherine Lankford posted a
picture to her Instagram where she had
red hair looking a lot like Pepper Potts
as hair there were rumors going around
that Catherine Langford's robe will be
playing a descendent of one of the
original six Avengers so her being the
daughter of Tony Stark and Pepper Potts
lines right up with that report and
there have been rumors going around
recently that Catherine Langford will in
fact play the daughter of Tony Stark and
Pepper Potts twenty-something years into
the future this implies that there will
be some sort of time jump and Avengers
endgame time-travel is all but confirmed
right now for Avengers in game and it
makes sense that the Avengers will not
only have to go back in time but also
forward in time because if they are
changing the events of the past they'll
have to see how these changes affect the
future so Tony may go forward in time
and see his future daughter and this may
be something Tony might have to
sacrifice in Avengers endgame he may see
a timeline where he has a full-grown
twenty year old daughter but perhaps
that timeline isn't when he defeats
Thanos and he might have to give up the
timeline with his daughter in order to
defeat Thanos and save the universe
there have also been talks about the
Young Avengers appearing in Avengers
endgame perhaps there is an alternate
timeline where she takes the armor of
her father and becomes a type of Iron
Man but for right now these are both
just speculation and rumors but it is
confirmed that Tony Stark and Pepper
Potts will be married and have a
daughter in Avengers end game and right
now all the evidence points to Catherine
Ling for its secret role in Avengers in
game being Morgan Stark Tony Stark and
Pepper Potts as daughter
but let me know what you think about
these rumors and reports and let me know
what role you think she'll play in
avengers endgame let me know in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe to my channel
comment down below and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway for the
life-size Infinity Gauntlet and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers in game as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]